this episode of the wi files is brought
to you by ship
station Mike fired up the box and the
lasers came to life the machine produced
a small circular area of distortion it
was a Vortex about 8 in across that
looked like ripples above a fire this
was unexpected Mike didn't know what the
vortex was or if it was dangerous so he
grabbed a sheet metal screw and tossed
it through the field it vanished Mike
just stared and blinked and waited the
screw was just gone so Mike powered down
his machine and turned to head back into
the house then he heard something
clattering it was the screw it rolled to
a stop about 2 ft from the box Mike
thought he invented some kind of
teleportation device he didn't Michael
madman Markham invented a time
[Music]
machine
yeah human I'm glad you picked up listen
I need two weeks off and I need to
borrow your truck well I need you here
for the next 2 weeks and there's no way
I'm letting you borrow the truck again
it took forever to get the smell out
that wasn't my fault the gas station hot
dog was tainted oh that reminds me I
need any spare beavers you might have
lying around I know I'm going to regret
asking this but uh did you say spare
beavers oh yeah my Beaver Virgil and
Wyatt dick it rowdy
Virgil and Wyatt those are to Earth
Brothers I know who they are why do you
what why are they name what are you
doing Gertie and I had this great new
business camel scented candles we call
them candles get it yes I I do and you
really think people are going to buy
camel scented candles you kidding me we
already got orders up to our Zoo that's
why I need a truck and the time off we
got to make all these runs back and
forth to UPS and the post office and we
just get into the holiday shopping
season and Gertie's poor hump is sore
from carrying all the
boxes oh well we can't have that H
between you and me I think she's
exaggerating to get more hump rubs but
what am I going to do I can't resist
plus I got to deal with all these people
calling about their orders this candle
took too long to get here this candle
doesn't smell Camy enough plus I'm
getting CLE tunnel syndrome from writing
at all the
labels get it couple
tnle because cop is a fish I get it why
don't you just try ship station you can
automate your tasks and save time and
money on shipping oh I believe you have
once again elegantly segued into today's
sponsor I most certainly did ship
station lets you manage all your
shipping needs from one easy dashboard
you can manage your orders print labels
process returns but it sounds very
useful yep ship station integrates with
Amazon Shopify Etsy wherever you sell
online and they can save you up to 89%
off ups and USPS rates yeah and I can
use that money to make more candles I
mean candles you sure can and ship
station has Automation and reporting
that makes scaling your business easy
yeah what it sounds like a holiday
miracle if I only had some kind of code
thingy for you know a free trial manage
all of your shipments risk-free this
holiday season with shipstation go to
shipstation.com
today and sign up for a free 60-day
trial that's shipstation.com
files that's it okay now about those
beavers why just why oh camels are
actually quite aromatic like a Musky
vanilla which is a soup sa of laac and
Beav you see they have these glands that
make this gel so you have to express the
glands to uh get the juice out express
beaver glands hey you got rubber gloves
don't you well yeah but I'm not going oh
I got to go the Beavers are loose in the
house again Virgil Wyatt get back here H
Gerty don't let Morgan back in AJ's
bedroom he really loves that
[Music]
pillow Mike Markham from stanbury
Missouri was an amateur inventor who
liked to Tinker he lacked formal science
training but he had a natural aptitude
for electronics the back por of his
house looked like a home appliance
graveyard old TVs radios and CD players
were all dismantled with their insides
spilled everywhere there were spools of
copper wire and magnets of all sizes his
current project was a Jacob's Ladder a
device that consists of two metal rods
which start close together at the bottom
and spread apart as they go up this
produces climbing arcs of electricity
but Mike had an idea for a modified
version of a Jacob's Ladder the first
thing he had to do was create a
Transformer more than meets the eye no
no no an electronic transformer a
Transformers are electronic hello how
else do you think they defeat the
Decepticons by talking sternly do you
mind if I continue fine fine fine go
ahead to get the Arc of the electricity
going in a Jacob's Ladder you need a
high voltage power supply typically in
the tens of thousands of volts now in
the United States the standard household
voltage is 120 or 240 Vol that won't do
so Mike built his own Transformer robots
in
Disguise sorry sorry it's out of my
system now go
ahead basically what you do is wrap two
separate coils of wire around a common
core one coil is connected to the power
source so in this case the fuse box on
Mike's house the other coil then has
more or fewer turns in order to step up
or step down the voltage so Mike sat
down and just started coiling wire after
about 400 turns he lost count but he
coiled enough wire to step up his
voltage from 120 volt to 20,000 volts
now he's got his power supply for the
climbing rods or conductors Mike
actually used wire hangers no wire
hangers
ever ah somebody out there gets
it how it's supposed to work is the
voltage is applied to the conductors
they electrical pressure then ionizes
the air particles between the rods
allowing current to flow The Arc starts
at the narrowest point where the rods
are closest together and then the heat
from the ark makes the air around it
hotter and less dense hot ionized air
has lower resistance hot air rises and
so the electrical Arc Rises along the
conductors but the arc won't start on
its own you need to initiate it manually
by moving the rods closer together or
farther apart it's touchy also if the
air pressure changes it won't work if
humidity changes it won't work air
temperature movement even a little bit
of smoke or dust in the air and it won't
work so Mike had an idea what if he used
lasers to heat the air around the
conductors this would lower the air
resistance ionize it and make the spark
ignite on its own at least that was the
plan so he removed the laser emitters
from a couple of CD players connected
his homemade Transformer and fired it up
no spark it didn't work as he was going
to disconnect the machine Mike saw
something strange hovering above the
device was a sphere of distorted air it
looked kind of like the wavy Mirage you
see over a highway on a hot day but this
wasn't some powerful ball of energy it
was hardly visible if you weren't
looking for it you'd miss it unsure what
this thing was or if it was dangerous
Mike tossed a sheet metal screw into the
energy field the screw disappeared Mike
just stood there for a second confused
he didn't know if the screw got
vaporized or what happened then the
screw fell out of the field and landed
on the ground a couple of feet away now
he repeated this experiment a few times
with the screw and every time the same
result he tossed the object in it
disappeared for a second or so then
reappeared out of the energy field now
Mike didn't know if his machine was
teleporting objects or possibly sending
them a few seconds in into the future
after a few more tests the machine
overloaded the lasers were dead and the
components were fried now even though
all that was left of Mike's invention
was a burnt out box of parts he knew he
was on to something so now he would
rebuild the machine but this time
instead of it being 18 in tall he'd
build it 8 ft tall and to do that he'd
need access to a lot more power and Mike
knew exactly how to get
it
[Music]
Mike Markham was pretty sure he invented
a time machine but to really test it
he'd need to scale up his invention his
prototype was only about 18 in tall now
he wanted to go bigger scaling up the
parts of the machine wasn't a problem
bigger conductors and even bigger lasers
were available the problem was power he
needed lots of it his house gave him 120
volts he stepped that up to 20,000 Volts
for the Prototype but his homemade
Transformer blew out after just a few
minutes if Mike was really going to
scale and test his machine he'd need
Transformers that could handle 50,000
volts or more without breaking a sweat
basically he needed the kind of
Transformer you see on power poles but
those are not easy to get and they're
not cheap Mike didn't have 15 to $2,000
to put into this experiment besides he'd
need more than one or two Transformers
he'd need a few so Mike had an idea a
bad
idea he knew there were six industrial
grade Transformers just sitting in a
yard doing nothing but getting rusty but
that yard was a substation for the King
City Missouri power company so Mike
called a couple of friends with pickup
trucks and in broad daylight drove to
the substation loaded up the
Transformers and drove away a few weeks
later he had his next version of the
machine the Transformers were connected
to the grid new lasers were in place and
the wire hanger conductors were upgraded
to 4T long 1/ in metal rods this thing
was a beast now the Moment of Truth Mike
powered up the machine there was a loud
crack a spark and then nothing his whole
house went dark the new machine knocked
out the power then Mike looked out the
window he knocked out the power in the
whole town it took some tinkering but
soon Mike was able to get the machine
running without causing brownouts all
over town and the Machine it
worked it created an energy field or
Vortex a few feet wide so Mike sent
objects through the vortex but this time
objects weren't reappearing a few
seconds later they weren't reappearing
at all the objects were just Vanishing
to who knows where one afternoon Mike
had a few friends over and they were
tossing small objects into the energy
field they wondered could a big object
go through yeah I'd like to say my
ex-wife through well a few of Mike's
buddies got behind the living room couch
and pushed the couch went into the
energy Vortex and was gone who yeah that
was the good news ah yeah what's the bad
news Mike's cat was on the couch at the
time yes so what's the bad
news so now everyone is just standing
there in an empty living room staring at
this whirling field of energy then they
heard a pounding on the front
door Mike opened the the door and there
were eight deputies on the property the
officer at the door had a search warrant
Mike's neighbors had reported a lot of
weird activity happening at the house
and it didn't take long for police to
put together Mike's project and report
from the power company of a lot of
missing equipment so whatever experiment
Mike Markham was planning would have to
wait because now he's going to
[Music]
jail
for stealing the Transformers and
stealing power Mike Markham got 60 days
in jail and 5 years probation and while
he was in jail Mike thought of different
ways he could make the machine more
efficient but there was no way for Mike
to build any of this he lost his house
he lost his job he was a pariah in his
town because of the brownouts it seemed
like Mike's time machine career had come
to an end but then something happened
his story made the news the headline was
Kansas City man tries to build time
machine on
porch a Missouri worker set out to make
a time machine on his back porch the
contraption he came up with was not
completely off the mark according to
scientists there are theoretical
physicists working on those areas and
it's not total nonsense according to the
chairman at the physics department at
the University of Missouri at Kansas
City the Stanbery police say the voltage
that Markham had diverted into the
contraption caused power interruptions
in and around the Northwest Missouri
Town of about 1300 Markham was arrested
January 29th on a felony charge of
stealing the Transformers from a power
Generating Station in King City he
pleaded guilty and last month was placed
on 5 years probation police said the
Transformers had a capacity of 12 to
76,000 volts each enough to easily cause
electrocution or an explosion Markham
who told police that he has 2 years of
college level electrical engineering
said he was building a time machine but
didn't have enough power for it that's
according to the Stanberry police chief
Tom Hampton and that headline caught the
interest of someone who had changed
Mike's life
forever let's
go from the high desert and the Great
American southwest I met you all good
evening good morning good afternoon
wherever you may be in the world's time
zones all of them covered amply by this
program Coast to Coast a.m. I'm artbell
it is my honor and privilege to be
escorting you through the second half of
the weekend and what a program it is
going to be
tonight if you're building a time
machine and you need help getting the
word out there's no better person in the
world to help you do that than Art Bell
I set out to find young Mr Markham and I
found him um Michael are you there uh
yeah good artbell interviewed Mike
Markham for about an hour and a half on
the Coast to Coast radio show not only
did Mike sound legitimate but he clearly
had considerable knowledge and expertise
in electronics and so did artbell let's
say it's 400 turns in your primary and
there's say there's 4,000 turns in your
secondary 10 times the turns and then
you'll get 10 times the voltage right
Watts amps voltages stepping up stepping
down art knew about all that stuff if
Mike was faking it he wasn't going to
fool our Bell well this was uh it was I
was using were waves where I could
actually it was easy controlling the
duty cycle is easy to control the
voltage that way right so cuz you can't
find you can't really find it's hard to
find varc rated at megawatts so man I'll
tell you if you using square waves I bet
the ham operators heard you for miles
and he didn't try to fool anyone Mike
came across as humble he wasn't looking
for fame or attention in fact Art Bell
is the one who tracked Mike down and
convinced him to come on the air
millions of people listened to that
interview that night and before long
people were calling in with offers some
had Transformers they would donate
others had property he can use and
plenty of people were ready to
financially support Mike in building a
new bigger machine how do you feel about
the possibility Michael of somebody
coming along and being your Mentor even
more than this maybe contributing money
to build a great big gigantic version oh
that'd be great that'd be like a dream
come true for the next few days offers
came in and Mike with his new team
created a plan he corresponded with a
few physicists and picked their brains
about his technology and how it could be
used for time travel several scientists
helped Mike come up with an idea for a
mechanism with rotating magnets that
would make the machine easier to control
so Mike got a warehouse all the
equipment he needed and access to more
power than he could ever use it took
about a year but he finally built a
newer larger and highly upgraded version
of his time machine and you know what
the machine
[Music]
worked it took almost 18 years but
artbell was finally able to catch up
with Mike Markham honestly art thought
Mike was dead and I called you madman
because I was convinced you were going
to absolutely fry yourself alive and
turn into a French friy there are other
people who have been involved in time
travel uh Mike that I've had on the show
and honest to God Mike they're gone I I
don't know where they are uh whether
it's Teter or Anderson others that we've
had on the show they're gone I mean
they're gone but Mike madman Markham was
very much alive and a lot had happened
since the last time he and art spoke
because of Mike's last appearance on
Coast to Coast he suddenly had a lot of
benefactors he had a little money
equipment and lots of power Mike set up
in a warehouse and over Park Kansas and
there he built several iterations of his
time machine the most successful version
used rotating magnets so instead of
having a small energy Vortex Mike was
able to create what he called a plasma
tornado maybe it'll be more efficient if
I use instead of using uh basically heat
from a laser in a cold room the
differential the the temperature
difference between those two to stir the
plasma maybe even more efficient if I
used the magnetic field to stir it that
that's what I ended up doing use the
magnetic field to do what um basically
it's uh well in simple terms this thing
looks like a basically a plasma
tornado so how much power do you need to
create a plasma tornado well remember
Mike's first machine that prototype ran
at 20,000 volts well his next version
the one that ate the couch and the cat
yep and what a waste of a perfectly good
couch stop it anyway the next version
used about 70,000 volts this new machine
in the warehouse which is about 15 ft
tall it was pulling 3 million volts that
is a crazy amount of pressure pressure
well in simple terms volts measure the
pressure of force driving the electric
current so think of electricity like a
water hose amps are how much water is
flowing through the hose or how much
power is running through a circuit most
households get between 100 and 200 amps
of power well unless you got a grow room
then you need a lot more power what did
I say about this Tomatoes I was growing
tomatoes anyway amps are the amount of
power voltage is the pressure of the
power so imagine taking that water hose
and making the end of it smaller and
smaller that increases the pressure of
the water coming out of the end so even
if you don't have a lot of amps you can
still create really high voltage that's
what a Transformer does so using juice
from the power company supplement Ed by
a couple of generators Mike had more
than enough power to run his
machine two cylinders one cylinder
inside the other right with a magnetic
with another basically a circle of
magnetic uh electromagnets around it so
basically you got uh a bunch of plasma
like inside of it with a magnetic field
rotating it you know what you are
describing I'm I'm sure you've heard
stories of The Philadelphia Experiment
right yeah well they
described a similar electronic setup uh
with regard to the rotating magnetic
fields art correctly pointed out that
this is how the Philadelphia Experiment
was done with high voltage and rotating
magnetic fields in fact when Mike was
arrested he told the police he was
building a time machine now of course
they thought he was nuts but several
scientists said that if building a time
machine was possible Mike's technology
was on the right track because
Einstein's equations do allow for time
travel and they're
blueprints blueprints for different
kinds of of time travel designs that are
compatible with Einstein's theory for
example gigantic spinning cylinders you
go around the cylinder and you come back
before you left so now Mike started
testing the Machine by sending objects
through the vortex first with small
objects like bits of wood baseballs and
little things like that and they went
through just fine but they just
disappeared just like the couch and the
C yet but they really didn't disappear
they just ended up in different
locations so what is teleporting stuff
no the objects would go in and vanish
and then about 2 minutes later they
reappeared but the objects ended up
between 50 and 150 yard east or west of
the machine and always East and West
never North or South Mike thought this
could have something to do with the
Earth's rotation or magnetic field and
look I know the story sounds crazy I
don't mind it but these tests were
witnessed by 15 people anyone who
donated money or equipment Mike let them
be a part of the project and those
people showed up I would have too and
it's a good thing there are so many
people on hand hamsters are fast uh wait
did you just say hamsters yep the tests
were so successful that Mike started
sending small animals through
specifically mice hamsters and guinea
pigs no more cats no Ah that's a
shame between the inanimate objects and
animals Mike had successfully tested the
machine about 200 times it seemed like
varying the voltage and the speed of the
magnets could adjust how far objects
were traveling before long Mike could
make a pretty good prediction of where
an object was going to end up and how
long it would take before reappearing so
at this point there was really only one
final test to try do you mean yep Mike
stood in front of the vortex took a deep
breath and jumped there was a flash of
light and Mike disappeared now remember
artbell had been following this project
closely he was even planning a trip to
the warehouse but when art checked in
looking for Mike nobody had seen him he
was just
[Music]
gone the media did pay attention and the
media did including me nationally went
on the air and said um madman is gone we
can't find
him
[Music]
when Mike came to he was not in the
warehouse he was lying in the middle of
a field somewhere with the worst
headache he'd ever
had and there was a big problem he had
no memory of how he got there he didn't
even know his own name so he got up and
just started walking now it took some
time but his memories slowly returned
eventually he hit Fairfield Ohio a
suburb of Cincinnati
and Fairfield is 800 Mi due east of the
warehouse in Overland Park Kansas but
Mike had no driver's license or ID of
any kind no credit cards no money so he
went to the nearest homeless shelter to
grab a meal and get his bearings when he
got to the shelter he saw a newspaper he
had jumped 2 years into the future Mike
took a few odd jobs and got together
enough money to take a bus back to his
Warehouse in Overland Park when he got
there the Warehouse was empty everything
was gone the machine all the videos that
he took of each test all his notes every
bit of documentation was all gone Men In
Black could have been the Men in Black
or it could have just been the landlord
who thought Mike was gone so he just
sold the equipment or threw it away no
way that stuff is still out there
somewhere it might be now Mike was
pretty sure he could recreate the
machine he felt he could remember 90 to
95% of the process but it would take a
lot of money the equipment in the
warehouse was worth a couple of million
dollars but Mike still had memory gaps
he couldn't remember whose donors were
his list of supporters was in the
warehouse and that brings us to Mike's
third appearance on Coast to Coast he
caught artbell up on everything that
happened and although he wasn't looking
for money once again people were ready
to
help this one guy suggests I'm actually
looking at the website now go go to tell
him to set up a GoFundMe account yeah
yeah Gund me or uh you know well that's
crowdfunding right art also recommended
that Mike pursue a book deal and Mike
admitted that he's no author but if he
teamed up with a ghost riter he could
certainly cover all the technical
details another suggestion was work with
the government no what would you would
you cooperate with them
or the thing with DARPA uh well I don't
have firsthand experience with them but
I'm willing to bet they try to
militarize
every I mean basically the check isn't
free and clear there's always strings
attached I hear
that smart man so Mike had options and
our Bell encouraged him to keep working
all right everybody that's it everybody
in the world wanted an update on madman
Markham and now you got it he's not
going to stop what's next for
madman only time will tell good
night
[Music]
and Mike Markham would continue his
research and continue to experiment Mike
wanted to travel again but he needed to
bring things with him so when he woke up
he could quickly get up to speed in case
his memory failed again a big problem he
kept running into was that nothing metal
could go through the vortex well metal
could go in but it was unpredictable so
sometimes metal would come right out
like those sheet metal screws or
sometimes the metal would explode in a
shower of Sparks but after some trial
and error mik discover that if a metal
tube was built a specific way it would
act as a faraday cage meaning that the
tube could travel through the portal and
reappear undamaged plus anything inside
the tube would be unaffected including
metal so Mike continued to document his
work and built a pretty large following
online one day Mike posted that he was
ready to go through again and this time
he would go through inside the tube and
he'd take his cell phone with him that
way he'd have everything he needs his
notes photographs even money it was a
great idea and that was the last anyone
had heard from
him as always Art Bell kept tabs on Mike
and was disappointed to hear that he was
gone again to where or when nobody knew
but during one radio show art took a
disturbing call the caller had found a
newspaper article from 19 30 the article
described a man who had drowned his body
had washed up on the beach the article
said he was found in a strange metal
drum and the only object he had on him
was a small rectangular device that
nobody could explain the man had no ID
so he was named John Doe but some people
had a feeling his real name was
[Music]
Mike when artbell fans talk about their
favorite episodes there are a few on
everyone's list Jonathan Reed's alien in
the freezer the man who flew over Area
51 the Mojave phone booth everyone loves
mels hole mels hole is a classic and
Mike madman Markham is on that list
artbell loved time travel stories and
nobody could weave a tale like art could
the third interview artbell did with
Mike was in 2015 and it's a master class
in storytelling art already had all the
information everything from the early
days of Mike building a Jacob's Ladder
on his porch Mike going to jail for
stealing the Transformers the test with
the animals the warehouse and Mike's
2-year jump in time but art teases the
story out slowly nothing is spoiled he
walks you through the story at the
perfect Pace giving you just enough
information to keep you hooked and we
were hooked and look Mike Markham
doesn't bring much personality to the
story but art knows enough about
electronics and physics to keep us in
the loop and all the technical stuff and
Art Bell never condescends to his guests
he never ridiculed them he made them
feel comfortable because art knew that's
how to get the story I think this is one
of the reasons why the Y files has
success with these topics where many
other channels don't I don't condescend
or ridicule I don't talk down to you and
no matter how Bonkers a topic is I don't
ridicule it I don't have to believe a
story to enjoy it and if you believe a
story that I don't great so here's a
piece of unsolicited advice to creators
who cover these topics with a a snarky
attitude you're making the story about
you and that's a mistake so madman Mike
Markham one of the best time travel
stories ever but is it true well there's
a lot of information about Mike on the
internet that isn't true in his last
interview with art Mike even debunks
some of those stories like he never sent
a cat through the portal but he did send
the couch through but no cat damn and
Mike addressed that article from 1930
where the man washed up on the beach in
a metal drum I was thought it was a
great twist but that never happened and
there's a current story going around
that Mike was still alive but homeless
and died last year also not true now I
don't want to dox the guy but Mike is
still around and unsurprisingly it looks
like he spent most of his career in
technology but what about the
machine well Mike Markham clearly knew a
lot about electrical engineering when he
built that prototype on his porch he was
only 21 years old and scientists did say
that his technology was on the right
track now they didn't believe he could
actually create a time machine but they
said if a theoretical time machine could
be built it would be done with high
voltage and magnetism Nicola Tesla
thought he could possibly see through
time using
electromagnetism and Einstein proved
time travel was possible with gravity
the higher the gravity the faster time
moves and in extreme gravity like near a
black hole time would move very very
fast fast if Mike Markham figured out a
way to create a Vortex of extremely high
gravity in theory that would work it's
already been scientifically proven you
can use gravity to dilate time well
basically I'm using electromagnetism
which is 10 to the 30th time stronger
right so I don't need I don't need
basically a black hole to do this art
Bell's audience called in with lots of
questions and criticism but Mike was
ready for all of it for example there's
something with time travel stories that
really bothers me let's say you had a
time machine that could move you 10
minutes into the future okay fine you
move through time but what about
space the Earth is spinning 1,000 mph
it's orbiting the Sun at 66,000 mph our
solar system Zips through the Galaxy at
over 500,000 mph and our galaxy moves
through space at 1.3 million miles hour
so where you're sitting right now in 10
minutes you'll move almost 990,000 miles
in space time machine stories never
account for this the Earth is always in
the same place but Mike Markham does
address this he says his machine stays
in sync with the gravitational center of
the earth so he's not only moving
through time he's moving through
[Music]
space I've linked to all three
interviews below you can hear Mike
Fielding questions very calmly he comes
across as humble and not trying to prove
anything remember he didn't pursue Art
Bell to tell his story art pursued Mike
every time really the main reason to be
skeptical of Mike markham's time travel
story is he's here if I figured out how
to time travel to the Future I'd do it
wouldn't you but who knows Mike is still
young maybe he's working on a newer
version of his time machine I hope he is
now people will roll their eyes at this
story and say Mike's crazy but the world
needs more people like Mike marham
because when time travel is invented and
I think it will one day it will be
invented by a
Madman thank you so much for hanging out
with us today my name is AJ you know
Heckle fish know the this has been the Y
files if you had fun or learn anything
do him a favor subscribe comment like
share that stuff really helps us out and
like most topics we cover here today's
is recommended by you so if there's a
story you'd like to hear or learn more
about go to the Wi files.com tips and if
you want deeper Dives on stories like
these check out the yfiles operation
podcast I release at least two a week
and it's available everywhere you get
your podcasts and if you need even more
wi files in your life check out the wi
files Discord it's a lot of fun and
there's something like 20,000 people on
there so there's always something
happening 24/7 and it's free to join a
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible I dedicate every
episode to you and we could not do this
without you and if if you'd like to
support the channel consider becoming a
member on patreon for as little as $3 a
month you get all kinds of perks like
access to these videos early without
commercials Early Access to products
like the Heckle fish talking plushy and
two live streams a week just for you
another great way to support the channel
is grab something from the wifi store
yeah grab yourself a Heckle fish coffee
mug and then pour something delicious in
there and sip it and drink it and then
when it's empty stick your fist in there
and then put on a heck ofish t-shirt and
grab yourself a heck ofish tug and plus
animal tucking fish style that's going
to do it until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
oh oh
yeah I play Bia Scara 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like I
should but then another conspiracy
theory becomes the truth my
friends and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends
I fear the crap cat I got stuck inside
M's hole with MK truck I Fe only true
where did Stanley curi fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there throughout well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe
I'm dancing with the
fish fish on Thursday night Wednesday
J all through the
night all I ever wanted was to just see
the truth to the one Su Fe off through
the
[Music]
night
the MTH man SIDS and the solar storm
still come to a got the the secret City
Underground mysterious number stations
Planet are to project State and where
the dark Watchers
found in a simulation don't you wor
the Black Knight satell lighted to me so
I can't believe I'm dancing with the
fish fish thday night
J the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so the feet all through
night fish on Thursday night they J you
and my me all through the
night all what it was to just hear the
truth so the B feet all through
the
Dan love
dance love dance good love dance good
dance good loves to Dan
C love to dance on the dance ball
because she is a camel and camels love
to dance when the feeling is right on
was in
[Music]
time